so for those who follow online uh
discussions and battles and polemics
there has been a recent polemic about
icons
um you know some people put out some
videos criticizing the Orthodox use of
icons
um and so
many people have asked me to respond and
in some ways I guess I will but I'm not
going to respond in the same manner I'm
not a person I'm not a scholar and I not
a big fan of the scholarly approach and
trying to justify this or that from
proof text and to justify the accuracy
or you know the falseness of this or
that Source or this or that text you
know I have nothing
against that it's fine and in some ways
I'll leave other people to do that but I
do think that there is a deeper issue
that gets ignored when we are
looking at the question in that way and
the deeper question is something like
the very thrust of Revelation itself the
very way in which God is Redeeming the
world in the biblical story and you
could say in the Universal story and so
that is the way that I want to look at
it to kind of look at things maybe back
up a little and ask questions that
people as they get into the details of
things
seem to not be asking and so that's the
way we're going to look at it
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
now of course the first way thing to
start with is to start with the text
right the the prescription which is that
in the Ten Commandments but not just in
the Ten Commandments obviously in
several other places there is a
prescription about making images that
prescription is let's say the root of it
could be said to be in the Ted
Commandments all the other
uh descriptions of it are like let's say
exemplifications or detailed version of
the law that you will not make graven
images uh You Will Not Bow Down and
Worship them you will not make images of
false gods and and you will not bow down
before them you won't worship the images
of false gods now of course
most people will understand that this is
not a prescription against images
themselves because you know just a few
moments although some people go that far
but I think that's quite dishonest
because further on in the text God will
tell Moses to have images made have it
have images made on the veils of the
temple have images made you know on the
Ark of the Covenant to have these angels
carved on the Ark of the Covenant and uh
and then ultimately in the temple there
will be several images there'll be Bulls
there'll be images of fruits uh and and
different types of images but the Cherub
are the most important to understand
because the Cherub are described as at
least partly human figures that that
have uh human faces
um we don't know what the cherubs look
like in the in the the carvings I
honestly think it was probably something
like a a sphinx of some kind you know
because they're described as being a
mixture of different animals and human
so that's neither here nor there so it's
so the idea is that it's not necessarily
of course a criticism of uh image making
but it is a criticism of making idols
and also bowing down and worshiping in
front of these Idols now
what's interesting to ask is
the questions that I guess some people
don't don't ask which is what's the deal
with the
second commandment what is the reason
for the second commandment as Christians
we need to ask that
why is there a second commandment so
another example of course there is a
commandment about uh you know following
the Sabbath which is right next to the
Commandment uh about images and
you know most Christians do not
celebrate the Sabbath and so why is that
why don't we celebrate the Sabbath and
the answer is usually Christ the answer
is that the reason for that let's say
commandment was revealed in the person
of Christ and you know Christ in his
descent into death let's say
accomplished the greatest Sabbath
and because of that we celebrate the
resurrection as a kind of new beginning
as the you know the Fulfillment of the
Sabbath into a day of eternity and so
that is the the reason why we celebrate
the the Deep reason you know why we
celebrate on Sunday rather than
celebrate on Saturday and we believe and
I hope people believe this or else why
are you not celebrating the Sabbath we
believe that the reason for the second
command this the the Commandment about
the Sabbath is
Christ and Christ reveals to us the
deepest meaning of this commandment and
so that is true of you know
I would say most of what is in scripture
if we can see in scripture the key that
Christ brings to it
then that is the highest aspect of it
and I think that that's the question we
need to ask again why do we have the
second commandment what is the purpose
of it and so of course it makes sense
that you wouldn't want to make images of
false gods because you know like you
won't want to worship false gods that it
would be of course completely
inappropriate but the question is why
didn't God give us an image of himself
and of course then the problem is well
of course God doesn't God is beyond that
right God is in heaven God is Spirit God
is Not uh
something that can be seen you see all
over in scripture right the the the
notion that
God is telling Moses that you cannot see
my face if you see my face it will
destroy you right it will it will it's
not in some ways that God doesn't have a
face but that his infinite face or
however you want to phrase it will
consume reality if you are if you come
into contact with it and so because of
that then Moses cannot look at God's
face and no one is allowed to look at
God's face now
again we have to ask ourselves the
question
what is the reason for the second
commandment and so we need to think
about it
also in another way it's like
is there a place in scripture where it
is said
that there is an image of God
can we find that
and I think the answer is yes
and I think the answer is that the image
of God in Scripture
is man
the image of God in scripture is Adam
and
this of course makes sense even more now
of the second commandment
because there is a sense in which
the image of God in man has been
tarnished or has been broken or has been
disfigured and so because of that
it is no longer accessible and this
seems to be something which is going on
in for example the very revelation of
the Ten Commandments because what
happens when God when Moses really comes
into the very presence of God
his face His Image the visual aspect of
him begins to shine with Glory so much
that just as in a lower way but just as
we cannot look upon the face of God the
Israelites cannot look upon the face of
Moses and he has to Veil himself he has
to cover his face because you could say
in some ways the face of the the image
of God is being restored in Moses
but it is too much for people to be able
to tolerate and so just as there are
veils on the temple Moses puts a veil on
his face in order to cover the radiance
of his transformation
this is pretty amazing things it's
pretty amazing if you kind of now start
to understand that there's something in
the very thrust of Revelation which is
moving towards this idea of the
restoration of the glory of God in man
the restoration of the glory of God in
the image of man because think about it
is visual that is he had to hide his
face from the sight of others because in
that face there was too much Glory there
was too much going on for people to be
able to stand now I
think that this continues on in the
notion of of the Revelation uh in
scripture and so there is this movement
from something like the name from
something like that which is invisible
that which is spiritual into that which
becomes visible and embodied that is of
course the very uh movement from the
glory of God into the Tabernacle itself
it is the same movement that I'm telling
you about how there's this glimmer this
transformation of Moses as he comes down
the mountain but this gets taken up as
Revelation progresses and that as God
promises to fill the world with his
Spirit to fill the world with his glory
so in the prophetic text we start to see
a very strange thing uh start to happen
so in the prophetic text all of a sudden
this image of man starts to appear and
it's very uh very fascinating because
what is going on in this question so in
the Book of Daniel and in the Book of
Ezekiel the prophets have this
perception they see on a throne
sitting next to God
you know let's say it's sitting and it's
important to understand that the figure
is sitting it's the figure is not
standing if the figure was standing we
would understand that the figure is like
an angel that is serving the King right
like a servant serving the king but no
there is a throne there and the figure
that is there is sitting on the throne
and in sitting on the throne he becomes
the one that is served the one that has
to be served by the angels and what does
what did the prophets see they see the
figure the image of someone like the son
of man of someone that has the image of
the son of man
this is very fascinating isn't it what's
going on all of a sudden the possibility
of seeing this figure standing next to a
sitting in the throne next to the next
to the throne of God and also being
let's say in the glory of God and so
right this image that Ezekiel describes
of the the four uh cherubs like these
four these four wheels of a chariot that
is like the Earth itself and above you
know sitting you know surrounded by a
rainbow uh on a throne is this image of
the son of man now of course you know
most Christians will understand that
what he's seeing is is the Divine logos
but already the logos as in the figure
of a man that is already Christ uh as
being the one who will now I'm gonna
push you a little bit who will restore
the image of God in man
and so this is what's going on that's
why he's seeing a son of man even before
we know who that is he's seeing a son of
man sitting on a throne next to God
because that in some ways is the plan of
God from you know from the fall itself
is to restore not even before that even
in the creation of man the the purpose
of God was to instill His Image into the
world you know uh and and now it is to
restore it in Christ so this is what is
going on so it's all kind of there in
the thrust of Revelation and we can
understand it like I said as a very
let's say as the very structure of
Revelation itself that is moving from
Heaven down to earth moving from the
invisible to the visible moving from the
you know the let's say
from the invisible uh or glory to the
our light into space and of course I
think also moving from name into image
um and the idea in some of these
polemical videos that the Christians at
the early centuries had no concept of
this at all where we're not at all aware
of any of at least the thrust of this
movement I think is is a little
dishonest so I'm going to read for you
uh a text an apocryphal text and it's an
apocryphal text that is not in Scripture
but it will it's an apocal text that was
written between the first and the third
Century it's called the life of Adam and
Eve and in this you get a sense that at
least the Christians and the late Jews
had an understanding of what it is that
was going on and the relationship
between the fall of Adam and the second
commandment
you know it's like I you always have to
ask yourself what is the second
commandment for what is its purpose
and so I'm going to read from you from
the book of the life of Adam and Eve and
so now it is the it's the devil speaking
the devil says
oh Adam all my hostility envy and sorrow
is for thee since it is for thee that I
have been expelled from my glory which I
possessed in the heavens
in the midst of the angels and for thee
I was cast out in the earth Adam
answered what does thou tell me what
have I done to thee or what is my fault
against thee seeing that thou has
received no harm or injury from us why
does thou pursue us the devil replied oh
Adam what does thou tell me it is for
thy sake that I have been hurled from
that place when thou was formed I was
hurled out of the presence of God and
banished from the company of the Angels
when God blew into Thee the breath of
life and thy face and likeness was made
in the image of God
Michael also brought thee and made us
worship thee in the sight of God and God
the Lord spake here is Adam I have made
thee in our image and likeness and
Michael went out and called all the
Angels saying worship the image of God
as the Lord God hath commanded and
Michael himself worshiped first and he
called me and said worship the image of
God worship the image of God the Lord
and I answered I have no need to worship
Adam and since Michael kept urging me to
worship I said to him why Dost thou urge
me I will not worship an inferior and
younger being than I I am his senior in
the creation before he was made I was
already made it is his duty to worship
me
when the Angels were under me heard this
they refused to worship Him and Michael
Seth worshiped the image of God but if
thou will not worship Him the Lord God
will be wrath with thee and I said if he
be wrath with me I will set my seat
above the stars of heaven and will be
like the highest
this is of course the oldest version of
the fall of Satan not of falling before
the creation of humans not before not
falling you know in this Ancient Ancient
way that is described in more recent
texts but Falling because he did not
agreed to bow down
to the image that God had put of himself
in the world in Adam let's say the late
Hebrews and the early Christians they
had a sense that there was a direct
relationship between the notion of the
image in the fall of Adam and the notion
of the image
in the second commandment I do believe
so and that and also not just that but
the movement in the revelation of how
the son of man appears sitting on a
throne next to God now of course this
will be come to be fully kind of
revealed in the person of Christ as
being the image of this son of man of
this restoration of the of the of the
image of God in man the restoration of
the place of man sitting on the throne
next to God uh in the person of Christ
and and the early Christian artists knew
this very very well and so some of the
very first uh some of the earliest art
that still let's say survives iconoclasm
uh in it you will see that this is what
they are representing so this is an
image of the Ascension of Christ from
the rabulla gospel which is a Syrian uh
gospel from the 6th century and so in
this image you see
a Christ as exact it's the Ascension but
it's the Ascension represented as Christ
being the son of man Christ being on the
Chariot of the of the cherubim you know
represented in this particular way with
the four heads and the wheels and the
eyes and that this is the restoration
this is the full revelation of what is
being hinted at of what is being
suggested in the Book of Daniel and in
the Book of Ezekiel
and so the idea that it might have taken
Christians time to fully understand the
scope of what the story of Christ was
bringing of what the Incarnation the
consequences of the Incarnation for us
is something that I can I can understand
you know and and I think that pushing
very hard to act as if the early fathers
of the church were completely aware and
hadn't totally you know dealt with what
was what the relationship between
what the consequences of all the
consequences of the Incarnation of
Christ were I I'm okay with accepting
that but it doesn't change the thrust of
what is happening and so it's
interesting because in you know in some
of the polemic videos there's this sense
that there is no difference between
veneration and worship that there is no
difference of levels between you know
bowing down uh and worshiping God in the
sense of acknowledging you know God as
being the highest and being the source
of all things and I think that that is
that's a dishonest take you know there
are many images of uh let's say the
relationship an honorable relationship
towards mediation in scripture you know
uh there is of course the the image of
Joshua who bow Downs before bow bows
down before the Ark of the Covenant you
know you have images different places
where people bow down to each other and
so the idea that people couldn't
distinguish bowing down before something
to honor it to see it in a vehicle let's
say of God's of God's grace or God's
presence and then the the absolute
worship of God himself I think that is
that's a dishonest statement uh you know
people did bow down before Kings bow
down before all these things and you
know about and the idea that there's no
relationship at all like bowing down
before a king
you know it's not connected in any way
to bowing down before other things it's
it's ridiculous it really is an
understanding of power and understanding
of authority an understanding of
something which is at least it is
showing us how the authority of God
works with us it's a mediated version of
God's uh God's Authority on us uh the
idea that we would be willing to bow
down to that is completely normal in in
the Old Testament uh and so I don't see
that I don't see that that's an honest
argument to say that there's no
distinction between the two
um
and the best example of that is actually
not in the physical bowing down but it
is in the way that the people in the Old
Testament
praise the name of God and so it's very
interesting right uh you see so many
examples of it right in uh Nehemiah 956
stand up and praise the Lord your God
uh who is from Everlasting to
Everlasting Blessed Be Your glorious
name it may be exalted above all
blessings and praise
uh of course in the Psalms there are so
many versions of this
um and it's interesting because in Psalm
there's a version of it uh and uh we can
look at it because it's fascinating it
says the Lord Reigns the nation's
tremble he sits and thrown between the
cherubim let the Earth shake and so it's
insane that he sits and thrown between
the cherubim the glory of God on the Ark
of the Covenant right
great is the Lord in Zion he's exalted
over all the nations let them Praise You
great and awesome name he is Holy the
king is mighty he loves Justice you have
established equity in Jacob you have
done what is just and right exalt the
Lord Our God and worship at his
footstool he is Holy and so it's
fascinating because in one of the
polemical videos uh there's trying to
deconstruct this as if this is not
suggesting that people are worshiping in
front of the Ark of the Covenant or that
the Ark of the Covenant is in some ways
the place that you bow down that you
that you are let's say relating to in
order to uh worship God but then just
you know two two two uh verses up you
see that there is a relationship to that
mediation because he's saying praise
your great and awesome name and then
after that he says exalt the Lord and
worship at his footstool and so both of
those examples are examples of praising
and elevating and and bring and let's
say uh acknowledging and you could use
the word venerating that's totally fine
the the the mediations that God gives us
that reveal him to us and so it's
important that you be able to tell the
difference unless you think that the
that the Israelites worship the name of
God in the same way that they worship
God himself and I don't think that is
fully that is acceptable in any way and
so the reason why they're able to
worship at the footstool the reason why
they're able to praise the holy name is
that these are mediations that God has
given
to them himself and so because God has
given this this this uh revelation of
him we are we celebrate we venerate we
raise up these these uh these mediations
um
because it's by these mediations that
we're able to encounter God in the world
so now you would say that's not true of
images and the answer is you're right
not in the Old Testament for sure that's
not true but why why is it not true why
is it not possible
God made an image of himself in the
Garden of Eden why can we not venerate
the image of God the way that we
venerate the name of God the way that we
venerate the Ark of the Covenant it is
because God is working to restore that
image in US
you know and there are already hints of
that right I think there are hints of
that already in the in the Bible where
you see uh people bowing down before
each other it's not totally clear like
there are different reasons why you bow
down but nonetheless the whatever reason
it is the lowering of yourself in front
of someone else has a structural
relationship you're lowing yourself and
you're raising up someone else when you
lower yourself you're raising up someone
else so there's no difference between
praising the holy name and bowing down
before something those are the same
thing they're both making yourself lower
in relationship to something so they're
they're just the same thing
um
so the answer to that is that God gives
us an image of himself God restores the
image in Christ and so the image becomes
a place of revelation of God and not
only would I go say that but I would say
that the reason for the second
commandment
the spiritual reason for the second
commandment is a promise that God will
give us an image of himself
that God will restore the image of
himself that has been tarnished and
broken
at the fall
and that is Christ so the image becomes
a mode just like the name becomes a mode
of Revelation
and
people will get caught up in the
technicalities of it like people will
say well we don't really know what Jesus
looked like so you can't really
represent him uh blah blah blah blah
blah like this is irrelevant this is
Irrelevant for the same reason you can
say well you didn't hear the name of God
in your ear when God said it so you
don't really know how to pronounce it
and so you shouldn't be you know you
shouldn't in any ways think that you
have access to the name of God uh
that it is a question of mode and so
when we praise the name of Jesus we know
that the way we say Jesus is not the
same way that it was said in the first
century uh and that's okay you know
that's not the point is not to be to be
to be completely technically accurate
obviously you can't I mean there's a
there's a range right there's a range of
recognizability you can't decide that
the name of Jesus is Oscar and then
prays the name of Oscar but it also
isn't about just about being technically
accurate the same thing is for the image
we have a way to recognize the image of
Christ we have a a way that has been
that has been fostered and received in
the Church of recognizing the image of
Christ and we see the image of Christ as
a mode of revelation of God and this
this is something that we should be that
I it's like I said I understand where it
took time for the Christians to see them
but it's something we should be
rejoicing of because it is a proof of
the rest of iteration of what it's a
it's an arc that starts in Genesis
and moves all the way into Revelation as
you know the the image of the holy city
which comes down from heaven the space
which is filled with the glory of God
you know then now the image of the son
of man sitting on a throne that you find
in Revelation you know is another
version of that is another version of
the fulling The Filling of the presence
of God in the world and so
I mean that's mostly what I wanted to
help you understand is that if you I
understand people getting caught up uh
in the in reading that Source text and
looking at what this or that church
father said or didn't say where the
holes and where the proof like that's
fine some people need to do that but I
think that the I think that the argument
uh
is made much far more deeply from the
very thrust of what Revelation is and
from the very thrust of the entire
Narrative of of scripture and so you
know as Orthodox Christian we see just
like we see in the name of Jesus and in
the name of God
a place where God has revealed himself
to us and so we we praise the name of
Christ we we praise the name of God uh
and we also see in the image a place
that God has revealed himself and that
that that Revelation is a is a
fulfillment I think
it's a fulfillment of a great story
which starts at the beginning uh in
Genesis
so I hope this has been useful and I
know it won't convince people that that
are looking you know to that that have a
kind of
let's say a technical way of reading
that want to just see the proof text and
the source text and and like and try to
to encode it that way and all I would
ask you to do is to maybe pull out a
little bit and ask yourself the bigger
questions the bigger questions of what
is the thrust of the entire story so I
hope this was helpful to at least some
of you uh thank you for your attention
and uh talk to you very soon